هو فين اصلا حبيبي انا شايف اب
[موسيقى]
كين لا انا مافيش كومنس قدامي اه
تمام تمام
اه بس ما فيش الكومنت ظهرت الكومنتس عندك
لا ل
طيب
احنا عاد البث هذه حلقه راعه استاذ السيد
الله يخليك
بس تمام طيب ماهو برض جون عمل لنا نفس
المشكله مش كده ولا نعمل فيه ايه ده بقى
نعمل فيك ايه يا جون عا البث هذ الله
يخليك ا السلام عليكم كنا انا كنت بتكلم
على سؤال بس محرق اللي ارسله ممكن يرسله
مره تانيه لانه معلش انا اسف اهم مني يعني
استاذ سيد لحظه عشان
الاسئله محمد والي بيقول لدي سؤال اظن انه
مختلف ومهم هل يمكن ان تعلم مصر ان اقت
غزه تحت الحمايه المصريه وتمنع رات من
التحليق في اجواء غزه مصر مش عاوزه غزه يا
محمد مصر واكيد الفلسطينيين مش عاوزين مصر
الفلسطينيين عاوزين يكون لم دوله يكون
عندهم على الاقل يعني استقلال ب لا مصر
عاوزه ده ولا غزه عاوزه ده ولا
اسرائيل مش عارف عاوزه ايه يعني دي قصه
محتاجه دراسه يعني ل ما كانش سيناريو
مطروح بس ما تريده اسرائيل على الاقل مش
ان
مصر اصل لو اسرائيل عاوزه مصر تحكم غزه
يبقى لها تفسير واحد ان حد يتولى هذا
المستنقع او الكابوس اللي هي هربت منه
وتبقى مصر مسؤوله عن القطاع اللي مافيش
فيه مقاومات الحياه وده لا من مصلحه مصر
وبصراحه مش هيكون في مصلحه اسرائيل لانه
ده ممكن يادي في النهايه ان يخلي مصر
عباره عن حراس للامن القومي او الحدود
الاسرائيليه يعني وكانها بقت سلطه
فلسطينيه بس بامكانيات كبيره لخدمه اذا
كانت اسرائيل اسرائيل عندها في في مطلوب
منها واضح مطلوب منها دوله فلسطينيه كل
الكلام ده هيبقى تنصل من التزام هي لا
تريده على حساب الاخرين اهلا اهلا يا
صديقي حياك الله مساء الخيرات استاذ سيد
اتمنى ماذا تتمنى يا صديقي اتمنى انك
تطلعنا على تاثيرات ما يحدث في غزه على
سوريا لا سوريا ان شاء الله هنعمل
عليها سوريا عاوزه حلقه لوحدها يا صديقي
فاستاذنتها
انه الاحداث غطت على التطورات الكتيره في
سوريا فمعلش ده عاوز
تفكير
وعاوز يعني دراسه هادئه كده مش اجابه
سريعه عليكم
السلام شرف السلام عليكم مصطفى ما رايك اه
انتم كنت بتقولوا اخونا ما رايك في م قاله
باسم يوسف في برنامج بيرس مورجن انا مش
متاكد من اسم مقدم البرنامج بس انا ما
وصلني واللي سمعته وتداولته وسائل الاعلام
مختلفه
لباسم يوسف من
انه ان سياسات اسرائيل اذا كانت دي اللي
بتقصد عليها عشان هو اتكلم كتير انها غير
مجديه وان اللي فعلته حماس لم يكن هو
السبب الرئيسي يعني اللي يعني ادى الى انه
يعني لو اختفت حماس ان اسرائيل هتبقى دوله
ملاك وايده 100% بل واثني عليه اذا كان هو
ده اللي انت تقصده لانه استطاع ان يعبر عن
هذا هذه الفكره بوضوح في وسائل اعلام
غربيه عاده لا نحسن
مخاطبتها انا بتكلم على رد باسم يوسف مش
اجمالي ما يقدمه باسم يوسف الذي لا اعرف
ماذا يقدم يعني لكن اللي انا سمعته وال
شفته انا شخصيا اثنيت عليه واعجبني كثيرا
استاذ السيد ركز على لايف
لانه لانه منحس لانه
معانا واحد من عيله فينا نتواصل
مع انا مش استاذ سيد ركز على لايف لانه
منحس انك او منحس انك موجود معنا واحد من
عيله ربنا يخليك ويسعدك اه انا كده فهمت
يعني ان انا اهتم ب لايف اكتر لان قريتها
منحس الاول منحس ماشي اشكرك يا احمد كتر
خيرك
اهلا سيد اهلا سيدبي انا مش ب ولا حاجه بس
اهلا وسهلا عاد البث مشكور استاذ سيد الله
يخليك عيشه اظن هل تحالف بريكزت سوف يضعف
امريكا يعني الاجابه المختصره نعم لماذا
لا تتحدث عما يحدث عما يتحدث عنه العالم
من ابلاغ مصر ليهود
و وتحذيرهم من قبل عمليه حماسه اتكلم عل
ايه وحد سالني وانا ماتكلمتش الك اللي
اتكلموا عليه كلام اولا قالوه الامريكان
انا ما عنديش دليل عليه ولكن بالنسبه لي
انا يبدو لي متفق مع المنطق اصله انت
بتتكلم في النهايه يعني عشان يكون ما
عندنا هو وضع عجيب غريب مصر علاقتها تتمنى
ان تكون السلطه الفلسطينيه هي الراس اللي
بيدير السلطه الفلسطينيه لا تتمنى ابدا ان
جماعه حماس تكون جماعه موجوده وتسيطر على
قطاع غزه هذا خطر بالنسبه لمصر القصه من
قبل الاحداث دي الخلاف المصري مع ا حماس
كجماعه وافكار وتوجه قديم ومن سنين من
ايام الرئيس مبارك هذه جماعه عندها
اجنده تخدم افكارها ما تخدم دوله زي مصر
مصر عاوزه اي تصعيد او تهدئه مع اسرائيل
وفقا لحساباتها مش لحسابات حماس اللي ممكن
تجرها في حرب لا تريده فانا بكلم لك
كتحليل مصر مش عاوزه حماس كمان بغض النظر
عن النقطه ديت لانها جماعه بتنتمي لجماعه
الاخوان والدوله المصريه في الوقت الحالي
بتعتبر جماعه الاخوان جماعه ارهابيه مصر
عندها مشكله مع حماس لان حماس عندها
متعدده الصلات بدوله مصر قطع العلاقات
معاها زي ايران مصر على صله قويه بقطر
اللي كانت مصر على خلاف معها لسنوات
فالعلاقه ملتبس
لكن في نفس الوقت رغم كل الخلافات ديت هي
بتشوف في جماعه حماس والجهات جماعات يجب
التعامل معها وفي جانب ايجابي انه في
الاخر في قلب كل مسؤول
مصري ازعم ده يعني كره لاسرائيل ورفض
لاسرائيل و تملون من اسرائيل ولا اتخيل
عكس ذلك الا استثناءات الاستثناءات فقول
ان مصر
تبلغ ان في حماس لا اعرف اذا كانت هذه
المعلومه لكن تبدو لي منطقيه لانه هيترتب
عليها اللي ترتب عليه الموقف السوي والصعب
جدا اللي فيه كل الاطراف فيعني عمليه
مركبه تتمنى ان في جماعه تلحق خسائر
باسرائيل عاطفيا نعم استراتيجيا بقى وواحد
بيدير دوله ده هيورت ني وورتني بالفعل في
اختيارات دلوقتي ممكن تؤدي لكوارث بالنسبه
لمصر وبالنسبه للاردن الى اخره في انت ما
سالتني وانا ما جاوبتش
يعني لماذا لا تعمل حلقات عن سوريا
والعراق نعمل يا صديقي والله حاضر
اا ثائر السلام عليكم استاذ سيد برايك ما
الشيء الذي سيفعل المقاومه بلبنان وايران
للدخول في الحرب الحاليه وفي حال حدوث ذلك
ما مدى اتساع رقعه الصراع وموقف دول
الخليج من التقارب مع ايران الجزء الاول
بانه حزب الله
يعني المفروض يعني انه حزب الله لا يسعى
لحرب على الاقل دلوقتي انا ماعرفش طبعا
حزب الله بيفكر ازاي ولكن انا في حدود
يعني ما يمكن استنتجه ببساطه ان افضل فرص
المواجهه لحزب الله ان يهاجم اسرائيل وهي
غير مستعده اسوا وقت الاختيار بالنسبه
لحزب الله انه يختار توقيت اسرائيل حشده
فيه
350 ال مجند ا يمكن بخلاف القوات الاساسيه
كمان ف وان العالم وفي حاملتي طائرات
وبوارج بريطانيه فهذا يعني جزء من نجاح
مثلا عسكريا عمليه طوفان الاقصى هي العنصر
المباغت الجزء الاساسي من نجاح حرب 73 كان
عنصر المباغته السبب الرئيسي في انه الحزب
الله الحق هزيمه او على الاقل خسائر هائله
في حرب 2006 كان عنصر المباغته ايضا من
جانب حزب الله والمباغتة
بس حزب الله اختار التوقيت واسرائيل كانت
نايمه في العسل ما عندهاش فكر عن كل هذه
القدرات انه دلوقتي حزب الله يعمل ده انا
ما اظنش ان ده توقيت عظيم لحزب الله ان
يفعله هل هو وقت مناسب وعظيم لايران اشك
في ذلك ايران
الان طبعا ممكن اكثر من تفسير ولكن هي
ممكن تستفيد من اداره اوراق الضغط وان هي
في ايديها القدره على ان تلعب دور الوسيط
التهدئه القدره على التصعيد فتبقى اوراق
ضغط تقدر تتفاوض بها مع الولايات المتحده
ومع غيرهم لكن هل من مصلحتها ان يلحق اذى
كبير بحماس وبالجهاد وبحز الله امر صعب
ا موقف دول الخليج ب معا
ايران يعني اصل كل المواقف يعني في الوقت
الحالي ما فيش اي سبب يدعوها ان هي يعني
تراجع عن لان هي تتراجع عن تقاربها مع
ايران هي لما تراجعت عن تقاربها مع لما
لما تراجعت عن معاداه ايران او الجفوه مع
ايران هي بحكم المصلحه والاقرار بالضروره
والواقع علشان يحصل تغير لازم هيكون
مجريات الاحداث اللي ماحدش يقدر يتوقعها ا
مشيت في اتجاه تاني خالص انا عاوزكم بعد
اذنكم يعني اللي مهتمين واللي عاوز يقرا
كاتب امريكي لبنان الاصلي اسمه نسيم
طالب اللي هو صاحب نظريه البجعه السوداء
او البلاك سوون اللي كلمتكم عنها مرات
عديده لكن هذا الكتاب وكتب اخرى له فيها
فكره مركزيه جميله لمن يستطيع
قراءه نسيم طالب اللي هي خلاصتها ان
الانسان سيء جدا في قراءه المستقبل وسيء
جدا في قراء البروبيلي او الاحتمالات
ولذلك دائما المستقبل
بيفاجئ بما لا
يتوقعه اح بنحاول نقرا بنحاول نستنتج
المنطق لكن كل شيء ممكن يتغير لانه قائد
ميداني في حزب الله قرر مثلا انه يضرب
كتيبه كامله اسرائيليه ولا سريه كامله
وتضطر اسرائيل ان تدخل على الخط وتضرب
هناك يعني مصالح ايران وتضطر ايران او انه
يعني الامور تبدا تشين ايفنس تادي الى ان
المنطقه كلها تشتعل نصم طالب انا ما
بيعملوش دعايه والله بس هو كاتب كويس
يعني ما حقيقه وقوف احنا
هستاذنك يعني كمان معانا 10 دقائق وا
استاذنكم نتوقف ونستانس ان شاء الله في
حلقه مقبله ما حقيقه وقوف روسيا وراء غزه
اجبته يعني استبعده تماما في رايي ان
المقاومه انتصرت ده السؤال ده كان بيساله
محمد انا اجبته موقف روسيا في راي ان
المقاومه ده ادهم انتصرت من اول يوم
وانتهى الامر ما لم تقوم اسرائيل باخلاء
القطاع واستئصال المقاومه للابد وهذا صعب
جدا ا ده راي كتير بيتفقوا معاك فيه يا
صديقي هو كل الحكايه انتصر وفشل عمليه
تقديريه توقف انت موقفك ايه كل الناس اللي
ابتهجوا بما فعلته حماس انه عنده موقف من
اسرائيل بيعتبر انتصار وكل الناس اللي
فوجئوا بهشاشه الدفاعات الاسرائيليه اعتبر
انتصار كل الناس اللي تضرروا انت بتوريني
ان الصوره حلوه يعني يا جون وكل الناس
اللي تضرروا من العمليه وبعضهم فلسطيني هو
طبعا حانق ومنزعج انا عارف ان كتاب
الاجابات النموذجيه بيقول ان الفلسطينيين
كلهم على قلب رجل واحد هذا غير صحيح في
فلسطينيين يتمنوا لو تتاح لهم الفرصه انه
يعبروا بكل الوسائل عن امتعاضهم مما فعلته
حماس لكن
هل تحويل انجلترا الى جمهوريه وعزل
العائله الملكه يغير من شكل العالم ولا
هيغير اي حاجه ولا هيغير حتى
لندن سلام عليكم هل المشروع الايراني هو
السبب في تعنت وتطرف
الاوروبيين في دعم اسرائيل المطلق لا
والله العظيم لانه الكلام ده كان موجود من
قبل 79 يا صديقي يعني ما هي الولايات
المتحده بدات في هذا الدعم من وقت مبكر
جدا جدا يعني وزاد بعد 67 وادراكها ان
اسرائيل ممكن تبقى فعاله بالاضافه ل
تعاطفها مع اليهود كمان اسرائيل الوليده
دوله فعاله فالدعم اللي تلقوه الامريكان
في بعد 67 وفي حرب الاستنزاف وفي 73 والى
ان قامت قبل ما تقوم اصلا الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه ما كانش ليه اي علاقه بايران
ابدا وبعدين انا مش عارف ايه هو المشروع
الايراني اللي الناس بتتكلم عليه بس دي
قصه
يعني ما هو سر الدعم يعني ايه الفرق بين
المشروع الايراني والمشروع التركي
والمشروع الاسرائيلي والمشروع الاثيوبي
الدوله موجوده وبتستخدم كل ادواتها لتحقيق
مصالحها وانت لازم تواجهها احيانا تتوافق
على مصالح واحيانا تواجهها لان مصلحتك
وجود ومخططاتك تضر البحرين وتضر الكويت
وبتحاول تعمل ده بكل الادوات المتاحه اليك
اذا كانت مواجهه او تصالح الى
اخره ما هو سر الدعم
المفرط من اوروبا والمملكه المتحده
لاسرائيل مما دفعهم لضرب كل القيم
والاخلاقيات التي ينادون بها عرض الحائط
ما ده اللي انا كنت بقول لك عليه في اول
الحلقه انا رصدته في حلقه لماذا يخاف
الرؤساء الامريكان ومنها تقدر تعرف يعني
فكره عن بس امريكا لانه الاوروبيين مش
بنفس هذا القدر الاوروبيين ا مش عازين
يزعلوا الامريكان برض مش عاوزين يعني
المستشار الالماني معقول هي جاهر مثلا
خصوصا الصوره اللي واصله ما انت عندك
اعلام
يعني حاجه تدرس في الكتب ان النهارده
اسرائيل تطلع انا فاهم ان من غير اي ضغط
انه اسرائيل بدل لكل العالم ان الامور
كانت هادئه هادئه هادئه يعني ايه يعني
اسرائيل بتقتل مثلا كل شهر اثنين لاثه
بيحموا المسجد الاقصى بيهجر الناس ده
بيعتبروه مش مشكله يعني ان ان فلسطين ان
حماس تعمل ده شايفين ان ده كان عدوان
لمرو لم
[موسيقى]
يتم لم يتم ما فيش سبب عملته اسرائيل لم
تستفزك اسرائيل فده بيعتبروه ان عدوان
حمساوي غير مبرر ماشي ممكن افهم ان ده
انما دول بالاعلام الاسرائيلي ومحبه
اسرائيل بقى تم تصديق صوره على ان دول
داعشيين وبيقتلوا الاطفال وبيغتصبو
وبيغتصبو ويقطعوا الرؤوس فطبعا طبيعي يعني
انه مع هذه الدعايه الاله
الدعائيه الاسرائيليه انه دول اوروبيه
اخرى مش كل الدول الاوروبيه
يعني هل تحالف بريكس اجابته لماذا لا تعمل
حلقات اجابته انا عملت الاسئله دي استاذي
يقال ان رئيسي يريد اخذ مكان خامنائي بعد
موته لهذا افسد الصلح السعودي الاسرائيلي
لا علم ليه ب ذلك يا صديقي
ا لكن هو بدون بدون طموحات رئيسي هو ليس
ابدا ابدا ابدا من مصلحه ايران على اي
مستوى ان يكون هناك تقارب بين السعوديه
واسرائيل اللي من مصلحتها ان يكون في
بينهم فرقه يعني دمغنا وجعنا من غزه صفاء
والله وقلوبنا كمان وجعتنا اكتر من من
عقولنا يعني
اا السلام عليكم لا تنسوا السلام عليكم هل
طوفان الاقصى ورت من
ايران يعني انا لان اجابت على السؤال كتير
فممكن ترجع لحلقه الدكتور احمد يوسف احمد
اللي من لاث اربع
ايام وانا وفي الاجابه انا استاذنكم نتوقف
عند هذا القدر انا عارف ان في اسئله ثانيه
كتير بس ان شاء الله في مرات اخرى جايه
كتير ولكن ما شاء الله كم كبير من الاسئله
بس يعني يعني طيب انا كمان ثلاث دقاق
لانه السلام عليكم ربنا يخليك شكرا جزيلا
محمود لغايه الساعه 10 الثلث ونتوقف هل
سيتم توطين الفلسطينيين في العراق كما في
مصر والاردن هوان شاء الله مش هيتم لا في
مصر ولا في الاردن عشان يتم توطينهم في
العراق
ا لماذا لا يدعم الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس مقاومه شعبه رغم ان الضفه الغربيه
منتهكه السياده ولا يريد ان يقاوم والله
هي اخونا
ا
98 يعني انا طرحت نفس السؤال ده بس يعني
هو طبعا الرئيس ابو مازن كان عنده اجنده
من زمان ان هذه المقاومه لا يعني تضر ولا
تفيد وانك تطلق طلقه واحده هتقتل بها جندي
اسرائيل هيقتله 1000 مقاتل فلسطيني
وبالتالي افضل حد ان احنا نتفاوض ونتفاوض
ونتفاوض كان كلامهم لا يخلو من المنطق بس
ثبت بالدليل العملي بعد 30 سنه من اصله
انه هذا الكلام لا ياتي بتيجه انا معلش
استاذنكم ان نتوقف عند هذا القدر انا عارف
ان في اسئله كثيره واتمنى اجيب عليها ولكن
زي السيد المسيح ما قال النفس راغبه
والجسد ضعيف فان شاء الله نلتقي في حلقات
اخرى سامحونا للارسال اللي تم على مرتين
سوف يتم اعدام جون عادل الليله على يعني
بوابه المكتب و ان شاء الله نلقاكم
بالمناسبه
في حلقه ثانيه عن
سيناريوهات الاجتياح البري لغزه
وهو المساله مش بنتكلم عسكريا لا احنا
بنتكلم مع الدكتور احمد يوسف عن التغيرات
اللي ممكن ينتج عن هذا الاجتياح سياسيا
سواء في فلسطين او للدول العربيه او لدوله
الاحتلال اسرائيل اشكركم ونلقاكم على خير
باذن الله الى اللقاء
تمام